En vídeos anteriores, aquí en VisualPolitik
hemos hablado ya de China - "en
los últimos años la presencia de china
en el continente africano". - " sólo en
Pakistán, China  que se ha hecho
también con el Puerto de Gwadar". -"El caso
más característico es sin lugar a dudas
dudas el de China".  Hemos visto cómo este
país se ha convertido en el mayor socio
comercial de África, superando incluso a
los mismísimos Estados Unidos o cómo
el gigante asiático está llevando a
cabo el mayor proyecto de
infraestructuras de la historia, qué conocido
como "La Nueva Ruta de la Seda" tendrá
implicaciones muy importantes en
Asia Central, Oriente Medio e incluso en
Europa.
Sin embargo, hay otra región prioritaria
para los líderes chinos que no podemos
olvidar: Latinoamérica.
Así es, amigos, China también está
apostando fuerte por el continente
latinoamericano. En este vídeo
vamos a ver qué está ocurriendo.
El desembarco chino en la América
Latina está haciendo enormes, en los
últimos 15 años las relaciones
comerciales entre China y Latinoamérica
se ha multiplicado por 22 hasta superar en 2015 los
230.000 millones de dólares.
Hoy China es ya el segundo mayor socio
comercial de la región,
el tercer mayor inversor y el mayor
prestamista. Y por cierto, todo apunta a
que el liderazgo comercial que Estados
Unidos aún mantiene, sucumbirá pronto
ante el empuje del gigante asiático.
- "China ha prometido incrementar su
comercio bilateral con la región a
500.000 millones de dólares en 2025".
De hecho, a día de hoy, China ya es el
mayor socio comercial de países tan
destacados como Brasil, Perú o Chile.
Y junto a esa tendencia económica
encontramos la política: Latinoamérica
es una prioridad para Pekín y las
autoridades chinas no han dudado en darle
a la región un rol destacado ¿cómo? Pues,
por ejemplo, el presidente chino Xi
Jinping, desde que asumió la presidencia
en 2013, ha realizado tres giras por la
región, más que cualquier presidente
anterior de China.
De hecho, Xi Jinping, entre 2013 y 2016
habrá visitado diez países
latinoamericanos, tantos como Obama pero,
eso sí, en la mitad de tiempo.
Y os preguntaréis ¿cuál es el objetivo de
tantos viajes? Pues fundamentalmente
estimular las relaciones comerciales,
porque curiosamente como ya vimos en los
casos de África y la Ruta de la Seda,
el comercio es la prioridad absoluta de
la política exterior china. Por su parte,
los líderes latinoamericanos, que cada
vez le otorgan una mayor relevancia a la
inversión en sus políticas de
desarrollo, también han comenzado a
frecuentar Pekín, una ciudad que cada
vez juego mayor rol en las relaciones
internacionales.
La mejor muestra de esta tendencia ha
sido la decisión de Pedro Pablo
Kuczynski,
el Presidente de Perú, que escogió a
China como destino de su primer viaje
oficial.
-"No estamos buscando créditos, ayuda
financiera,
lo que estamos buscando es inversión y
cooperación a nivel internacional".
Es verdad,
hubo un momento en el que parecía que
China se acercaba sobre todo a los
países dominados por gobiernos de
izquierdas o de corte populista, pero la
verdad, amigos, es que eso no es en
absoluto algo que le importe a Pekín,
más allá,
eso sí, de que estos países suelen
mantener peores relaciones con
Washington.
- "En este mismo lugar huele a azufre todavía".
Por lo que evidentemente suelen resultar
más accesibles, pero nada más.
Hasta el momento china ha firmado
tratados de libre comercio con Perú,
Chile y Costa Rica; y actualmente
mantiene conversaciones con Colombia y
el bloque que conforma Mercosur.
- "Lo que dijo ese señor chino, que vino el otro
día, la propuesta que nos hizo, que lean
ese discurso detenidamente. Que nunca, yo
no me acuerdo que en América Latina
nadie vino hablarnos
y a proponernos esas cosas, y es
un envite de características globales
como nunca hemos tenido y no debemos
dejar perder esa oportunidad".
Así que, todo apunta a que en poco tiempo las
trabas al comercio habrán desaparecido.
Los objetivos del gobierno chino,
precisamente, van en esa línea y son muy
ambiciosos: en los próximos diez años
quieren doblar las relaciones
comerciales y multiplicar por tres las
inversiones chinas en América Latina.
Sin ir más lejos, en 2015 Xi Jinping
anunció que China invertirá en esta
región al menos 250.000 millones de
dólares en los próximos 10 años.
Y además, aunque hasta ahora el grueso de las inversiones
se había concentrado en los sectores
ligados a los recursos naturales y la
obra pública, cada vez es más habitual
que las empresas chinas comiencen a
operar en este territorio
o compren directamente empresas
latinoamericanas de diferentes sectores.
Compañías de petróleo, de electricidad,
bancos o incluso empresas de
explotación pesquera,
el dinero chino comienza a llover sobre
todo tipo de negocios.
Todo esto ocurre justo en un momento en
el que parece que Washington, con la
nueva administración Trump, no sitúa
precisamente a Latinoamérica como una
prioridad estratégica.
De hecho, lo sabéis, mientras que el
gobierno chino no deja de hablar de
inversiones mutuas y aperturismo, el
nuevo presidente de Estados Unidos
dedicó gran parte de su campaña a
criticar el comercio con México y a
prometer deportaciones y muros.
Lo cierto es que no hubo muchas palabras
cariñosas hacia América Latina por su
parte.
Y está,
además, el asunto del TPP, sobre el
cual Donald Trump ha dicho que se opone
a su ratificación. Y este tratado
afecta a varios países latinoamericanos.
Pues bien, China lleva tiempo trabajando
en una alternativa al mismo en la zona
de Asia - Oceanía,
pero claro, a tenor de los
acontecimientos ya se está hablando que
podría incluir también a países de
América Latina. Se conoce como
"Asociación Económica Integral Regional"
y si finalmente Estados Unidos
no ratifica el TPP podría convertirse en
la referencia económica del Pacífico, y
claro, como podéis imaginar,
en ese caso el protagonismo y el
liderazgo recaerían en Pekín y no
Washington.
Y, ojo, si hay un país que despierta la
obsesión de Trump ese es China.
Por todo esto, no sería extraño que en poco tiempo el tablero de
disputa entre China y EEUU se extendiese
a Latinoamérica. Bien, pero ¿esta
relación con China, es buena o es mala?
Estoy convencido de que esta es la
pregunta que muchos os estáis haciendo
así que tratemos de responderla.
Más de 80% de las
exportaciones de América Latina a China
recaen en una agricultura que en general
genera poco valor añadido, y en la
minería, que es una actividad poco
intensiva en mano de obra.
La soja, el cobre, el petróleo y
el hierro, son los cuatro productos que
dominan las exportaciones
latinoamericanas a China.
Por contra el grueso de las
importaciones corresponde a productos
industriales,
así que aquí vemos un primer problema:
Si Latinoamérica no afronta reformas en
favor de la competitividad esta
integración comercial puede traducirse
en una desindustrialización creciente y
en un modelo económico que genere pocos
empleos.
Por no hablar del déficit comercial, que
a tenor de esta situación crece
año a año. - "Por segundo año consecutivo,
Bolivia tiene un déficit comercial al tercer
trimestre del año con 835 millones de
dólares". Un segundo problema tiene que
ver con los préstamos que China viene
realizando a los gobiernos de la región.
China es exigente con los acuerdos que
firma, de tal forma que fija siempre
tipos de interés bastante altos, y para
garantizarse el cobro suele contemplar
el pago en especie. Por ejemplo, gran
parte de los préstamos que China le ha
hecho al gobierno de Correa en Ecuador
serán reintegrados en petróleo. Esto
hace que la presión financiera sobre
los gobiernos sea menor,
al fin y al cabo no necesitan dinero, pagan
con recursos naturales. Pero que nadie se
llame a engaño, los intereses
implícitos son altos, muy altos. Y China,
además, también suele obligar a que los
proyectos sean realizados por empresas
chinas y con tecnología también china.
" - Se calcula que China lo domina ya un tercio
del sector minero peruano.
En concreto en la explotación de cobre,
siendo las empresas asiáticas las
mayores productoras de este mineral en
el país".
El resultado es que si los gobiernos
latinoamericanos tienen la tentación de
gastar más de la cuenta o no evalúan
correctamente los proyectos en que van a
invertir el dinero prestado,
pueden encontrarse con un escenario
donde la explotación de sus recursos
naturales acabe en manos de Pekín. Y por
supuesto China tiene suficiente
influencia y poder como para lograr que
todos los préstamos se paguen. Aquí
no cabe hablar de auditorías de la deuda,
moratoria, ni de suspensiones de pago
Por último, existe también cierta
preocupación con que los cuestionables
métodos de trabajo chinos, en terrenos como las
normas ambientales o la opaca gestión
empresarial puedan extenderse por el
continente. O, también, consolidar la
pobre consideración hacia la seguridad
en el trabajo.
Hasta aquí los riesgos.
Por supuesto, junto a ello, también son
muchas las oportunidades que abre las
relaciones con el gigante asiático.
China puede facilitarle a Latinoamérica
los recursos que este continente
necesita para financiar infraestructuras
e industrias esenciales, y, además, les
ofrece a sus empresas el acceso a un
mercado gigantesco. Prácticamente
podemos decir que China es una
alternativa a Washington y a Donald
Trump.
Personalmente estoy convencido de que
China puede jugar un papel muy positivo
en Latinoamérica,
siempre y cuando, claro, sus gobiernos
aprovechen estas relaciones  para
impulsar el comercio, atraer inversiones
y modernizar sus estructuras productivas.
Ese es el reto. Bien, ¿tú qué opinas? ¿Debe
América Latina abrazarse a China?
¿Tolerará Donald Trump que Pekín asuma
tanto protagonismo en esta región o
tratará de impedirlo? Espero vuestras
respuestas, y como siempre decimos si
aún no estén suscritos podéis hacerlo
ahora pulsando sobre este botón. Os
prometemos que en VisualPolitik
estaremos muy atentos a todos los
movimientos del gigante chino.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima, amigos.